we're told that ABCDEF is a regular
hexagon and this regular part hexagon
obviously tells us that we're dealing
with six sides and you could just count
that you didn't have to be told it's a
hexagon but the regular part lets us
know that all of the sides all six sides
have the same length and all of the
interior angles have the same measure
fair enough and then they give us the
length of one of the sides and since
this is a regular hexagon they're
actually giving us the length of all of
the sides they say it's two square roots
of three so this side right over here is
two square roots of three this side over
here is two squared so three and I can
just go around the hexagon every one of
their sides is two square roots three
they want us to find the area of this
hexagon find the area of ABCDEF and the
best way to find the area especially of
regular polygons let's try to split it
up into triangles and hexagons are a bit
of a special case maybe in future videos
we'll think about the more general case
of any polygon but with a hexagon what
you can think about is if we take if we
take this point right over here and
let's call this point G and let's say
it's the center of the hexagon and when
I'm talking about a center of the
hexagon I'm talking about a point it
can't be equidistant from everything
over here because this isn't a circle
but we could say it's equidistant from
all of the vertices so the GD is the
same thing as G C is the same thing as G
B which the same thing as G a which is
the same thing as G F which is the same
thing as GE so let me draw some of those
that I just talked about
so that is GE there's Gd there's GC all
of these lengths are going to be the
same so there's a point G which we can
call the center the center of this
polygon and we know that this length is
equal to that length which is equal to
that length which is equal to that
length which is equal to that length
which is equal to that length we also
know that if we add if we go all the way
around the circle if we go all the way
around a circle like that we've gone 360
degrees and we know that these triangles
these triangles are all going to be
congruent to each other and there's
multiple ways that we could show it but
the easiest way is look they have two
sides all of them have this side and
this side be congruent to each other
because G is in the center and they all
have this third common side of two
square roots of three so all of them by
side-side-side
they are all they are all congruent
what that tells us is if they're all
congruent then this angle this interior
angle right over here is going to be the
same is going to be the same for all six
of these all six of these triangles over
here maybe I call that X that's angle X
that's X that's X that's X that's X and
if you add them all up we've gone around
the circle we've gone 360 degrees and we
have six of these X's so you get 6x is
equal to 360 degrees you divide both
sides by six you get X is equal to X is
equal to sixty degrees X is equal to
sixty degrees all of these are equal to
sixty degrees now there's something
interesting we know that these triangles
for example triangle GBC and we can do
that for any of these six triangles it
looks kind of like a Trivial Pursuit
piece that we know that they're
definitely isosceles triangles that this
distance is equal to this distance so we
can use that information to figure out
to figure out what the other angles are
because these two base angles it's an
isosceles triangle the two legs are the
same so our two base angles this angle
is going to be congruent to that angle
if we could call that Y right over there
so you have Y plus y which is 2y plus 60
degrees plus 60 degrees is going to be
equal to 180 because the interior angles
of any triangle they add up to 180 and
so subtract 60 from both sides you get
2y is equal to 120 divide both sides by
2 you get Y is equal to 60 degrees now
this is interesting I could have done
this with any of these triangles all of
these triangles are 60 60 60 triangles
which tells us and we've proven this
earlier on when we first started
studying equilateral triangles we know
that all of the angles of a triangle are
60 degrees and we're dealing with an
equilateral triangle which means that
all the sides have the same length so
this is two square roots of three then
so is this this is also two square roots
of three and this is also two square
roots of three so pretty much all of
these green lines or two square roots of
three and we already knew because it's a
regular hexagon that the every out each
side of the hexagon itself is also two
square roots of three so now we can
essentially use the that information we
can use that information to figure out
actually we don't even have to figure
this part out I'll show you in a second
to figure out the area of any one of
these triangles and
we can just multiply by six so let's
focus on let me focus on this triangle
right over here and think about how we
can find its area we know that length of
DC is two square roots of three we can
drop an altitude over here we can drop
an altitude just like that and then we
if we drop an altitude we know that this
is we know that this is an equilateral
triangle and we can show very easily
that these two triangles are symmetric
these are both 90-degree angles we know
that these two are 60 degree angles
already and then you just if you look at
each of these two independent triangles
you'd have to just say well they have to
add up to 180 so this has to be 30
degrees this has to be 30 degrees all
the angles are the same they also share
a side in common so these two are
congruent triangles so if we want to
find the area of this broader truck of
this little slice of the pie right over
here we can just find the area of this
slice or the sub slice and then multiply
by two or we could just find this area
and multiply by 12 for the entire
hexagon so how do we figure out the area
of this thing well this is going to be
half of this base length so this length
right over here let me call this point H
D H is going to be the square root of
three and we we hopefully we've already
recognizes this is a 30-60-90 triangle
let me draw it over here so this is a
30-60-90 triangle we know that this
length over here is square root of three
we know and we already actually did
calculate this is two square roots of
three although we don't really need it
what we're really needing to figure out
is this altitude height and from 30 60
degree nine 30 60 90 triangles we know
that the side opposite the 60 degree
side square root as the square root of 3
times the side opposite the 30-degree
side so this is going to be square root
of 3 times the square root of 3 times
the square root of 3 square root of 3
times the square root of 3 is obviously
just 3 so this altitude right over here
is just going to be 3 so if we want the
area of this triangle right over here
which is this triangle right over here
it's just 1/2 base times height so the
area of this little sub slice is just
1/2 times our base just the base over
here actually
be let's let's take a step back we don't
even have to worry about this thing
let's just go straight to the larger
triangle GDC so let me let me rewind
this a little bit because now we have
the base of the height of the whole
thing if we care about if we care about
the area of triangle G DC so now I'm
looking at now I'm looking at this
entire triangle right over here this is
equal to 1/2 times base times height
which is equal to 1/2 what's our base
our base we already know it's one of the
sides of our hexagon it's two square
roots of three is this whole thing right
over here so times 2 square roots of 3
and then we want to multiply that times
our height and that's what we just
figured out using 30-60-90 triangles our
height is 3 so times 3 1/2 and to cancel
out we're left with 3 square roots of 3
that's just the area of one of these
little wedges right over here if we want
to find the area of the entire hexagon
we just have to multiply that by 6
because there are 6 of these triangles
there so this is going to be equal to 6
times 3 square roots of 3 which is 18
square roots of 3
and we're done